let's say I have some linear
transformation T from r2 to r2 so if
that is r2 and then this is r2 t just
maps from any member of r2 to another
member of r2 just like that and I'm
going to define T it's a linear
transformation I'm going to define it
when I when I take the transformation of
some member of r2 it's equivalent to
multiplying it by this matrix by the
matrix 1 minus 3 minus 1 3 so just to
kind of understand this transformation a
little bit more let's think about all of
the values that it can take on in our
codomain so let's set it equal to so if
we say that 1 minus 3 minus 1 3 times
any vector any vector in our domain so
x1 x2 it's going to be equal to some
other vector in our codomain let me call
that vector BB is a member of r2 so it's
going to be equal to b1 b2 all I'm doing
here is I'm essentially if I call this
right here I call that matrix a I'm just
trying to find out what are all of the
possible values for ax is equal to B I'm
trying to find out all of the possible
all of the possible bees in this case
all the possible bees so if I were to
solve this equation for any particular B
what I would do is I would put this in
reduced row echelon form well first I
would make an Augmented matrix of it so
I would put a 1 a minus 3 a minus 1 and
a 3 and I wouldn't it with the member of
our codomain we're trying to be equal to
so b1 b2 and then I would put in reduced
row echelon form so how can we do that
how can we put in reduced row echelon
form I'll keep my first row the same 1
minus 3 and then b1 and then my second
row I'll replace it with my second row
plus my first row so minus 1 plus 1 is 0
3 plus minus 3 is 0 and then B 2 plus b1
is well I could just write that as b1
plus b2
so this is only going to have solutions
I have an interesting situation here
we've seen it before I have a row of
zeros I have a row of zeros and the only
way that this is going to actually have
solutions is if this thing right here is
also going to be equal to zero so the
only only members be that are of members
of RM that have have solutions are the
ones are the ones where if you add up
their two terms so let's say you know B
is equal to B is equal to B 1 and B 2
are the ones where that the two terms
added up have to be equal to 0 B 1 plus
B 2 have to be equal to 0 or another way
you could write it is that B 2 has to be
equal to minus B 1 so if we would
actually draw our codomain let's do it
we always stay in the abstract but
sometimes it's useful to draw an actual
example so let's say that our codomain
is r2 let me draw some axes right here
let's say that this is my this is my B
one axis and this is my B two axis I
could have called that x and y but I
call that B 1 and B 2 what are all of
the members of my co domain that have a
solution that have my mapping well B 2
has to be equal to minus B 1 B 2 s to be
equal to minus B 1 so it's going to look
like this it's going to be look like
this let me draw it's going to be
aligned with a slope of negative 1 this
is this is all the B's all the B's that
have solution that have a solution right
because if you're not on this line if
you're a member of your codomain this is
the codomain right here our two our two
is also our domain but let me make it
very clear that this is the co domain
that I've drawn this is what we're
mapping into it's very clear that if
we're not on this line if you pick
somebody whose two terms don't add up to
equaling zero or aren't the negative
each other
if you pick someone over here in our
codomain and then you try to solve the
equation over here you're going to have
a zero is going to equal some nonzero
number here and you're not going to have
a solution
you're not going and we touched on this
in the last video and so in this case
the image we could say that this right
here is the image of our transformation
is the image of our transformation or
even another way of thinking about it
obviously if all of if all of if all of
our two is this is our codomain let me
draw a domain if our domain looks like
this if all of our two so if you take
any member of our two and it's always
mapping onto something onto that line
clearly each point on that line is going
to be mapped to by more than one vector
so we're not dealing with an onto
transformation and we saw that in the
last video in order for something to be
on two when you put it in reduced
row-echelon form you cannot have all
zeros in one of the rows or another way
to say it in reduced row-echelon form
every row has to have a pivot entry but
let's focus on the B's that actually do
have a solution so let's focus on these
B's so that when you take a b1 plus b2
it actually is going to be equal to 0 so
you know we could have we could have the
B I don't know that could be the b5 5
minus 5 or you could have the B well
obviously the b0 0 is going to work you
could have one negative one maybe that's
right there let's focus on those for a
second and solve and see how many guys
how many members of our domain map into
them so if we take this right here and
then we apply this equation up here we
only have one constraint we're assuming
that this is going to be equal to 0 so
let's assume let's assume that we're
dealing with the bees in our image so
let's assume let's assume that we're
dealing with something where we can get
a solution that b1 plus b2 is equal to 0
then what is our constraints what we'll
map to our vector B that word
with so if we just take this top
equation right here we have 1 times x1 1
times x1 let me switch colors we have 1
times x1 1 times x1 minus 3 times x2
minus 3 times x2 is equal to B is equal
to b1 and then this row will give us no
constraint because this is just going to
be a bunch of 0 so this is the only
constraint for a member of our domain
that will map to some particular B now
that we are picking some particular B
that satisfies this constraint so we
could write this solution set let me
rewrite it as X 1 is equal to B 1 plus
3x 2 or if we wanted to write the entire
solution set it would look like this X 1
X 2 is equal to the vector B 1 0 plus
let's see X 2 X 1 is B 1 plus 3 times X
2 so plus x 2 x 3 and X 2 is just going
to be equal to X 2 we can that's a free
variable so X 2 is equal to 0 plus X 2
times 1 so what we're saying here is
look this transformation just maps to
this line here for all of the vectors in
our codomain where they're two entries
add up to each other now assuming let's
assume that we actually have one of
those vectors and so first of all this
is definitely not an onto transformation
but let's assume that we are dealing
with one of those guys so if we are
picking a particular one of those guys
for a particular B let me write this
down for a particular for a particular B
that has a solution that has a solution
that has a solution to ax is equal to B
the solution set the solution set the
solution set will be equal to this thing
right here it'll be equal to X 1 X 2
equal to the first entry of your bb10
+ X 2 times the vector 3 1 and if you
think about this if you pick a
particular B so let's say we pick our
let me let me draw this out because I
think it's nice to visualize it all
actually maybe I'll draw it like this I
don't want to draw our blobs anymore so
let me draw my axes so my axes look like
this we know that the image of our
transformation is the line with a
negative 1 slope because the two entries
have to be equal to the negative each
other let's pick a particular B let's
pick a particular B that has a solution
so let's say we pick that'd be right
there in order for it to have a solution
its entries have to be the negative of
each other so let's say that's the entry
let's say the C entry 5 minus 5 that is
our B so what we just showed is that the
solution set if we want to say hey what
in our domain maps to this guy so let's
think about what in our domain maps to
this right here let's think about what
in our domain maps to this point right
here to this particular B so that's
going to be all of the all of the X's
that satisfy a X is equal to 5 minus 5
and what this is selling it so this is
going to be equal to so the solution set
is going to be equal to so x1 x2 is
going to be equal to b1
it's going to be equal to 5 0 plus x2
plus any scalar multiple any scalar
multiple of the vector 3 1 so our
solution set is going to be you take the
vector 5 0 so maybe the vector 5 0
specifies this position right here and
then you're going to add to it
multiples of the vector 3 1 the vector 3
1 looks like this 1 2 3 and you go up 1
the vector 3 1 is going to go to look
like this it's going to look like this
so if you add multiples of this
multiples of that could stretch out like
that or it could go negative like that
to this vector 5 0 you're essentially
going to let me see if I can draw this
neatly
you're going to end up with a solution
set that looks like that right there
so if you pick if you pick a particular
B right there that has a solution we
just said that everything on this line
everything on this line will map to that
point in our solution set everything on
that line would map to our solution set
and in fact if you picked another point
let's say you picked let's say you pick
the point -5 5 let's say you picked let
me write it this way -5 5 then the
solution set that maps to that would
actually be you would take - this first
term would be the minus 5 would be here
and all of these guys all of these guys
would map to that what this is all
interesting I mean we've been doing a
lot of abstract things and I think it
might be satisfying that you're actually
seeing something kind of more concrete
in this example but I'm doing all of
this for a reason because I want to
understand what the solution set is to a
general non non-homogeneous equation
like this and to understand a little bit
better let's imagine what is the
solution set if I were to pick this guy
if I were to pick the 0 vector if I pick
the vector this is the 0 vector right
there then what's going to be the
solution set it's going to be the vector
so if we say that ax is equal to 0 then
our solution set is going to be the
vector 0 0 + right 0 0 + x 2 x 3 1 so
it's going to be what it's going to be
this is just the 0 vector so it's going
to be here it's going to be here and
it's going to just be multiples of 3 1
so it's going to look like C it's going
to look something like that but what's
this what is the solution set to the
equation of AX equal to 0 this is the
null space this by definition is the
null space this is the null space of a
this right here is the null space of a
so notice and this is the big kind of
takeaway from from this video is that
for any solution
you know we're picking B's that actually
do have solutions because we're picking
them on this line we're picking them in
the
image of our codomain but any the
solution set to any ax is equal to some
B where B does have a solution it's
essentially equal to a shifted version
of the null set this right here this are
the null space this right here is the
null space that right there is a null
space for any real number X to any
scalar multiple of three one is the null
space I just showed it right there it's
going to be that and so all of these
other solution sets are just some
particular vector some X particular plus
the null space plus the null space
obviously this vector by itself would
also be a solution to ax is equal to B
because you could just set X to to be
equal to zero so in general and I
haven't proven this to your vigor
rigorously but hopefully you you kind of
get the intuition behind it the solution
and I'll do this in the next video just
cuz I realize I'm running along on time
the assuming assuming a xB a xB has a
solution as a solution in the example we
just did we as we can assume it has if
we pick one of these points here so
assuming it has a solution if we pick a
point off of our image we're not going
to have a solution but assuming a xB has
a solution the solution set the solution
set is going to be equal to some
particular vector is going to be equal
to some particular vector some
particular vector so you can just think
of it as a set with just one vector
right there with or combined with or the
union of that set with all your null
space with your null space with your
null space of this matrix right here I
haven't proven this to you yet but
hopefully you get the intuition why this
is true we just solved it for particular
cases that do have solutions we say hey
it's going to take this form and I just
showed you that this is the form of the
null space this thing right here is the
null space and the reason why we're
doing that is because we've been talking
about invertibility in order to be
invertible you have to be you have to be
on 2 & 1/2 1
and for something to be one-two-one
one-two-one you have to have at most one
solution at most one solution for that
maps to a particular vector you might
have none but you might have at most one
so in order to have at most one solution
and the solution set is always going to
be equal to this so you're always going
to have this solution so in order to
have at most one solution your null
space can't have anything in it or it
can just have the zero vector so it's
just going to have to be so that means
that your null space the null space of a
has to be to be trivial or just to have
to be empty or just to just have just
have the zero vector I'll do this a
little bit more rigorously in the next
video but I think when you do it
sometimes with the rigger you don't
necessarily get the intuition but this
is going to be a very interesting
takeaway and I think you already
understand that this leading up to
conditions for invertibility